ich habe das seit Monaten nicht
hochgeladen ne ebay fails mit laserlaka
herzlich willkommen Oldtimer steht seit
25 Jahren in der Garage nur 72 km
gelaufen zu verkaufen denkt man sich
wahrscheinlich erstmal geil dicker
verkauft jemand seine schönen Oldtimer
richtiges Schätzchen schlägt man zu hört
man auch gern 72 km nur gelaufen dann
schickt der Typ der den Oldtimer
verkauft allerdings ein Foto und das
sieht so aus
[Musik]
soll ich den mit mir Helikopter oben aus
der Decke rausheben oder was hallo ich
interessiere mich für die Couch wie sind
denn hier die Maße liebe Grüße marie hat
leider kein Maßband aber mein Kollege
ist ein Meter 90 das
wären no joke ich auf eBay Kleinanzeigen
wow
toller Körper du machst was her sag mal
wie armselig muss man sein Leute auf
eBay Kleinanzeigen anzumachen kostenlos
ich sag ganz ich habe dicker gestern
wirklich ich hatte auch mit der Straße
rumgemauert ich sag's dir ehrlich du
hast jetzt an drei Tagen mit 50 Typen
was gehabt
so
safetes Dankeschön an eurem
übertriebenen Support beim Podcast nicht
nur sind wir mit der meist gehörte
Podcast in Deutschland sondern haben
auch den tiktok Podcast
wer nervt Sandra und ich sind in jeder
Kategorie die es auf tiktok irgendwie
gibt durchschnittliche likes likes
generell Follower watch time keine
Ahnung was der Top Podcast im kompletten
Deutschland Österreich Schweiz
Ding danke dir hey ich hole ab top heute
jetzt zu besoffen
hätten wir schon einer irgendwie vorher
mal sagen können dass jeder von seiner
sein wird rosen sind rot
Frauen online Chats dann scheinbar hast
du nur massive Eier im Netz der stark
der ist richtig strong viele ebay fails
sind kompletter Käse aber das ist der
strong beim nächsten Mal schreibt jemand
um 17:33 Uhr hallo wollte nur kurz
fragen ob es bei 18 Uhr bleibt und der
andere antwortet um 18:56 Uhr ja klar
sie schreiben mir um 18 Uhr 56 das ist
bei 18 Uhr bleibt ja in 15 Minuten da
Bro
Uhren lesen muss man da auch noch mal
lernen würde TV gern kaufen wäre 80 Euro
möglich wo ist es kann nachher
vorbeikommen 150 Euro mehr als 100 geht
leider nicht biete 75 an wird ja immer
weniger naja Gerät wird auch immer älter
aber recht
wo er recht hat hat was ist das
eigentlich auch für dummes Deutsch
Sprichwort wo er recht hat hat er recht
Bro ja als ob wir es oder hey darf ich
fragen was der letzte Preis wäre hallo
wie viel würden Sie denn Zahlen liebe
Grüße könntest du mir mal bitte die
Länge und Höhe ausmessen damit ich ca
weiß wie groß die Tasche ist will etwas
größer als man jetzige haben wenn sie
natürlich nichts ausmacht dann schickt
er das mit Bierflaschen gemessen und
schreibt daraufhin das hier hab leider
nicht zum Essen da kann die Tasche auch
gerne befüllen passt sehr viel rein das
macht er dann noch
Flaschen rein aber als crossbuddy würde
ich dann nicht mehr tragen alles klar
beim nächsten ebay-film verkauft jemand
eine DVD oder ein interessant der die
DVD auch schon gekauft hat
was soll der Scheiß ein lieber Nutzer
hat auf jeden Fall eine DVD von einem
anderen eBay kleinanz
[Musik]
ein ebay kleinanzeigen Benutzer hat eine
DVD von einem ebay kleinanzeigen
Verkäufer gekauft und da geht's nur noch
jetzt um die Abwicklung wie man das
ganze Ding versendet oder was der bei
ebay kleinanzeigen auch eigentlich das
abzuholen von der fragt er hallo wäre es
möglich die DVD abzuholen liebe Grüße
nein
darf ich fragen warum ich hasse
menschliche soziale Kontakte war nicht
mal bei der Beerdigung meiner Oma weil
mir dazu viel Verwandtschaft war Porto
ist für eine DVD aber auch nicht die
Welt
kein weiteren Fragen als nächstes wird
hier ein VW Polo verkauft und wie das
natürlich so ist wenn man auf Ebay ein
Auto verkauft oder auch kauft als
interessant möchte man natürlich einiges
Wissen von daher schreibt der Verkäufer
ganz freundlich möchtest Du etwas wissen
interessant antworte daraufhin wie viele
Vorbesitzer gab es kann ich morgen
gucken kommen meinst du Auto passt auf
Dachgepäckträger
habe großen Mercedes ML
der Typ heißt übrigens jarak
[Musik]
yarak will allen Ernstes
ein VW Polo kaufen und ihn mit einem
Auto abholen aber das den VW Polo oder
nicht auf dem Anhänger packen sondern
auf den Mercedes ML
[Musik]
bei mir ist die Befehl wurde auch schon
alles das Geld angeht vorher geregelt
die sind sich einig geworden Geld wird
bezahlt es geht nur noch um die Klärung
der Abholung des Produkts von daher hat
der Verkäufer geschrieben bleibt es bei
heute Abend ja Adresse geschickt und
noch dazu geschrieben geben Sie am
besten kurz bevor sie da sind Bescheid
der Käufer hat daraufhin dann
geantwortet eine Stunde später sorry
aber ich fahre jetzt wieder nach Hause
wie kann man denn nicht erwähnen dass
man drei Erdkunde Lehrer und einen
eigenen geostationären Satelliten
braucht um durch die Baustelle zum Haus
zu finden ich bin nicht aber glaube ich
aber da steht hier unter keinem guten
Stern
und der lacht einfach nur
ich schwöre Euch beiden Gott es gibt
nichts schlimmeres als wenn du einen
Termin hast den du einhalten musst und
eine Baustelle blockiert die Einfahrt
kommst nicht durch bei mir geht es um
eine Sache die glaube ich zu jeder ebay
kleinanzeigen Nutzer schon mal irgendwie
erlebt hat und zwar möchte man ein
Produkt für einen gewissen Preis
verkaufen was die absolute Schmerzgrenze
von einem selbst ist der andere will das
einfach nicht wahr haben von daher
schauen super was wäre denn der Endpreis
ist eigentlich ein Festpreis aber wir
können uns gerne noch 30 € einigen
machen wir 20 hole jetzt ab mit
freundlichen Grüßen david hat sich das
Thema erledigt schönen Tag noch senden
sie mir ihre Adresse
am Arsch Allee 26 sehr gut Bruder
standharz Bruder im nächsten ebay
kleinanzeigen fail hat die liebe Sabrina
etwas gekauft und das hat sie auch schon
bezahlt das Paket ist allerdings immer
noch nicht angekommen dann hat sie diese
Nachricht bekommen heiserina habe gerade
gesehen dass das Geld angekommen ist bin
jetzt aber schon in Österreich ich kann
das Paket erst am Montag wegschicken
hoffe das ist okay als Entschädigung
bekommst du einen kugelbild
ja ich glaube da braucht dieser Sabrina
das eigentliche Produkt ja auch gar
nicht mehr wenn Sie ein Bild hat beim
nächsten ebay kleinanzeigen fail wird
ein Sofa verkauft und ein interessant
schreibt diese Nachricht moin mit großem
Interesse habe ich diese Anzeige gelesen
bei dem Sofa gibt es keine
Gebrauchsspuren das ist schon mal gut
wie sieht es denn mit Geruchsspuren aus
wurde oft auf diesem Sofa gefurzt am
besten wäre natürlich wenn man bei jedem
Furz aufgestanden wäre viel besser wäre
es gewesen den Raum zu verlassen damit
das Sofa kein Ohr nimmt ich hoffe Sie
können mir da weiterhelfen mit
freundlichen Grüßen
hallo
wie alt ich 26 die Maschine also doch
ich
in dem Fell sehe ich mich auch ein
bisschen wieder und damit meine Damen
und Herren würde ich sagen kommen wir
jetzt auch schon zum letzten überfeld
für heute Roses are red my English mir
latte ich verkaufe auf Ebay Tisch
tennisplatte
an der Stelle bin ich raus
chenden
lassen aber